my name is Greg out I'm John Humphrey
I'm well Ashley Edgar thank you for
joining us yes you're only here for
image appeal you've seen the movie it
right yes
well today we're gonna watch from looper
disturbing it's moments from the book
cut from the movie oh boy oh let's when
do you 17 big screen adaptation of
Stephen King's novel it's it's a major
success with critics and audiences doing
no small parts of the way the movie
incorporates the books most essential
elements while sidestepping some of its
more controversial or uncomfortable
moments these are the most disturbing
scenes from its that were left behind
during the long journey to theaters
Patrick hot stares cruelest act in the
movie patrick hochstätter is hardly a
central figure to the story he's clearly
a jerk but not nearly as terrible as he
wasn't the novel Patrick isn't
exceptionally disturbed younger man in
the book a diffuse seem to show that
more than when he suffocates his baby
brother in his crib oh why was this cut
for the movie they need to save time and
narrow the narrative focus oh maybe the
filmmakers just have no interest in
getting quite that dark Patrick's deaf
seals our baby the 2017 movie Patrick's
deaf scene is entirely different than
the way it goes down in the novel he
dies in the barren sewer drain while
stalking the losers on paper however
Patrick's death is a little more
disturbing after he and Henry find
themselves alone in the woods Patrick
makes a sexual advance on
who ends up leaving eventually left
alone
Patrick is attacked by the EDS in the
form of swarming bugs a death that
matches his worst nightmare and we bow
was interesting us a movie heavy bombers
father as portrayed as an alcoholic
police officer who has no qualms about
the costing his son in front of its
friends but aside from the gun scene his
cruelty is mostly Internet in the book
however Henry's home life is a lot more
messed up boy babblers as a Marine
veteran who's developed psychosis unders
verbally and physically abusive to his
family including Henry
the only thing can be seems to be able
to do right by his father is act upon
their shared racism against the Hanlin
family the town place the 2017 s movie
handles White's history in very obscure
terms with solders parents died in a
gruesome house fire and that had seen
them burn which is why he's so haunted
by the image of burnt hands reaching out
from the meat store Sally entrance he's
shown us a bearer of some bad news about
the town's history courtesy of his
grandfather but for the most part the
role of the resident historian of the
group is given to Ben homestead the book
goes into a lot more detail about Mike's
pain
the notorious sound fire reference and
the movie took place our club called the
black spots and his dad was there the
night it was burned down it's also
Mike's dad who encourages him to study
the town sinister history which is how
he becomes the librarian and the only
ones have stayed in Derry after the rest
of the losers Club leaves the death of
Eddie Corcoran not only is Eddie
Corcoran story one of the most tragic
subplots in the book but he didn't even
make it into the movie as students at
the safe school as the losers Eddie
stepfather kills his little brother with
a hammer which leaves any on the run for
his life he ends up in the Barrens where
he encounters is which takes the form of
his recently deceased little brother
before turning into a Gilman and the
Kappa taking Eddie
Oh Eddie's first encounter anycast Brax
first encounter with it in the movie is
whether too many guys he passes by the
creepy house on the Bob streets and runs
into a leper which is a combination of
his worst fear of severe and contagious
illnesses in the book however there
seems a little more adults many readers
thought Eddie's mother also started as
emotional and sexual maturity by
demanding that all his affection be
reserved for her
the leopard doesn't make fun of his
medication instead he offers to perform
sexual favors in exchange for cash to
fear his sexuality most likely because
of communicable diseases little too
happy to explore in a single scene so
it's easy to understand why it was
ditched the goon squad hermie Bowers is
shown tumbling down the well to his
possible death in the 2017 movie and the
site burn Patrick the rest of his body
crew seems to get out of the movie
without getting hurt in the book however
they're all caught by it in the sewers
after chasing the losers Vica gets his
head torn up by the creature
whoa it's monster and a belt shatters
face ripped in half after trying to
defend Henry so yeah it's all a lot more
graphic in the book the ritual of
churning the ending appeared to
certainly simplify two things when it
came to the losers first banishment of
the Beast
once they rescue Beverly from a floating
curio States they have fearless against
the creature after they managed to
injure it by striking its head the
monster sleeps into the well and the
killing stopped for now in the book
however there's a lot more to it a whole
lot filled Emma brain uses an ancient
technique called the ritual absurd which
takes him into the Microverse where he
encounters the universe's creator a
giant turtle named
Mattern the turtle informs him that he
can only defeated in a battle of wills
and Bill weakens it enough for the
losers can make a physical attack it's a
much more supernatural
celeste to your process and what we see
on the screen and if it is any
indication the forthcoming sequel may
also bypass this bonkers aspect of the
story so the smoke hole the movie also
completely emitted a book scene that
would probably be regarded as
insensitive on film in the scene bill
uses a Native American snow called
ritual in an effort to find out more
about the demon terrorizing Gary biller
Richey end up staying in the hotbox long
enough to realize that a is an evil
force that's sucking the lifeblood out
of the town it's a realization that
works just as well with a rudimentary
history lesson but it's a clear example
of the movie avoiding the necessary
controversy which is pretty interesting
since there's still a movie about kids
battling a child eating monster of
course as controversial as that would
have been it's nothing compared to a
sewer escape this is probably the most
infamous scene that never made it from
the poses of being in any version in the
movie the losers have no trouble exits
in a sewer system after their battle
with it in the book however they find
that they can't remember the way else
the solution at their own suggestion all
six of the boys have sex with Beverly
Marsh in a quick succession so they can
be united again and find their way back
to the Barons abusive or even empowering
for Beverly
but even Stephen King himself has since
walked back on his value to the story I
wasn't really thinking of the sexual
aspect of it the book dealt with
childhood and adulthood
intuitively the losers knew they had to
be together again
the sexual acts connected childhood and
adulthood it's another version of the
glass tunnel that connects the
children's library I'm the adult library
times have changed since I wrote that
scene and there is now more sensitivity
to those issues like the 99
TV mini-series 2017 say it's basically
non-stop parts of the plot which saves
the filmmakers a lot of trouble bringing
the problematic scene to life not to
mention saving a lot of moviegoers from
a pretty awkward conversation wouldn't
they go home
thanks for watching subscribe my youtube
channel plus check out what this cool
stuff we know you're looking yay I don't
get the last thing why do they all have
to have sex with winter to find their
way yes they have they have to stay
connected they gotta stay connected in
order to do anything I don't know I'd
need to read the book to understand at
all with that the justification is I've
heard is that yeah they have to stay
connected but that's the most
explanation I get on it they all unify
as one so they're all like one stronger
entity so that's why they're all having
sex with Beverly and they oh I guess
grow in some I mean if if they all
wanted to stay connected their sexual
activity than they all should have had
sex with each other
why basically there was a lot more in
like the book there was a lot more
sexual stuff like fantasies a lot more
murder than and a lot more murders yeah
I mean there's like yet a baby in the
crib thing being suffocated oh yeah yeah
I don't know if I could have handled
seen babies killing and all that mother
oh yeah half the movies just killing
babies yeah I want everyone to think
that going in
you know what I kind of think that would
have been cool though if they kept in
the movie was the like him getting eaten
by bugs yeah because that just could
have been cool I didn't really show how
he died or they you just saw everybody
coming at him or whatever but I mean
with other people they showed their
fears I just think it's like the bug
thing and him being attacked by all of
them like swarm would have been well
there's just skin crawling and easy to
relate to fear you know yeah but at the
same time the whole like bug crawling on
fans I've ever seen it done in like so
many movies I think I'm like The Mummy
or even that clip from like Indiana
Jones for that they showed here it's
associated with things like that I feel
like it might have been too familiar at
the same time like they they said in
that moment he comes on what's the fat
kids name I'm sorry
plump child's name yeah I feel like
there's sort of things they cut because
there's some stuff where you're like we
can't have child actors going through
these kind of things no he's not he's
not that important character let it be
and and for a movie you need to keep it
more contained you know if it's a show I
can see how like they'll explore these
random other areas yeah but for a movie
now you gotta you gotta have the focus
be a lot more solid well yeah I imagine
you could probably take that edge and
smooth it out as it means to like build
this tension you know ya know the dread
of Pennywise / it and we don't focus as
hard on it right yeah you're not the
point the movie I've seen the it
miniseries and in the miniseries Michael
the black kid out of the white losers he
is the one with all the historical
information as a child he comes in later
into the group so that all plays out
like how it does in the movie the thing
with the movie though is I kind of felt
like his character was really pushed to
the background and they didn't really
serve that much of a purpose for a lot
of it the movie pretty much starts off
with him and then he comes in like way
later yeah yeah it feels like kind of a
weirdly
like a side story that doesn't clean the
game even
is it because I thought the Ben
character already had the thing about is
too big yeah the overweight you're gonna
shelf onto stuff and then they made him
that historical kid but I'm like well
having Michael show up later in the
movie and him being the historian what
if it had his character sort of a much
bigger purpose racism is over and now we
got empower fat people like they're
sitting on the benches like my
grandfather believes at this town he has
a pivotal line the trailer makes it look
like he's gonna be a part of this movie
and like you could kind of cut him out
of that made me really sad to actually
you could kind of cut him out and give
his lines to somebody else and not much
change it out you know a couple details
he brings in the thing yeah yeah yeah
the like slow down yeah so he brings
that to the table because that is used
or is it if you haven't seen it it's
pretty obvious when the opening scene
has that weapon you know it will be used
later in well the other thing too is
like every time I hear about what's cut
out of a Stephen King movie you know
from the book or whatever like listening
to all these facts and stuff reading
that book I would be like this sounds
like the worst possible place to live
like everything is arranged everyone's
like doing these horrendous crime well
Frank's the youth of these parents like
all the parents are messed up and all
the kids are like cutting each other and
like murdering babies ribs well I like
that thing with Eddie that's more hinted
at in the miniseries for me with Eddie
be having this mom forces her child to
only show affection to her I kind of got
that as it was then you get a sense of
that I feel like it's probably way more
clear-cut like in terms of affection
that's that's communicated pretty well
in the movie I feel like the sexual part
yeah would have been a little but then
again I'm like but there's a kid we had
the whole like sexual thing going on
like
and her dad you know like it might have
been like a lot of like child parent
sexual stuff going on because you've got
that fully every story needs a little
bit of you've already got that with her
storyline that's true marry a parent you
know yeah I think we can we can give and
take
I mean but the moms not like molesting
him I still found it creepy anyway like
she's gonna show you there is way too
you know what I mean like probably
what's way too long just think more like
an abnormally until he's like six years
old that's long where she makes him come
back and give her a kiss goodbye
so weirdness there yeah yeah that's true
a good amount of this stuff is basically
things that appeared in the movie but
were brought way down because they
talked about the racism to with the main
bully kid I forget his name but they
talk about he's like super racist and
stuff and he's like really out to get
fighting the dad yeah yeah yeah and
that's one thing we're in the movie I
was like I wish you guys gonna utilize
that more yes a like nowadays it would
resume I don't I just felt like they
took the time to acknowledge it but they
didn't actually use it for much I feel
like they gave up just a lot more
attention to Ben instead yeah instead of
seeing scenes of the black kid getting
bullied for being like the one black kid
in Derry getting bullied it's like no
let's give the the overweight kid the
historical knowledge and we'll give some
focus on him getting bullied he did
stuff yeah I'm glad though that they
didn't because when I heard that this
movie was coming out I was nervous that
they were gonna go the route of like
showing like you know like the turtle
thing like yeah really weird
what am i are too it might be there
because that is the origin of it well
and that's the stuff that I yeah that
makes me most curious about part two
especially cuz there's so much from so
many of these Stephen King adaptations
where you hear like wow these books are
almost famous like these are fantasies
like they're these weird straight like
every time
you're about a Stephen King book I'm
like this sounds so weird
I've seen the it miniseries and I hated
the part with the adults couldn't stand
it the parts of the kids were still fine
as far as the orgy scene goes I think
they should have included it no do you I
think they should have I don't think so
do you that's what would make this film
a classic if they went through some
boundary yeah this movies this movies
for [ __ ] that would add I just want
to see the sees the pre-production
meeting where they're like okay now we
can't show any of this we can't any of
the child actors do this so how do we
frame it we didn't get like stunt actors
and we can't let the shoes know of what
the scene is that we're doing Stitch
their faces on later I mean I have them
being connected by their that's good
that's good enough ready is good enough
for me yeah I don't think it's necessary
at all it sounds disturbing it sounds
super disturbing because they're to me
like it's kind of like a little love
story to and I just feel like it would
have ruined that you mean if you weren't
part of a group of friends and they all
felt like to be connected on adulthood
change people change
she's not the person I love it well guys
it's in the movie theaters is doing well
and everyone can't stop talking about it
sub your scribe shins to the real
rejects clickety click click click click
of the notification Bell - John Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram
Ashley ed nur is Ashley ed nur on
Instagram Twitter um you know what I do
but I don't go on it you don't tweet now
it's a bunch of old stuff you're never
like Trump is an arrow
you never like I don't even feel sorry
for Kevin Hart's wife you do man no
there's plenty of great things to say
got a good zinger in there you hatched a
get smashley boom oh yeah and I'm
painting Twitter just for that how to's
Morgan a nationally is her YouTube
channel I've got a couple videos there
she never invites me back I do
we gotta you gotta teach me some money
trying every time I've been on have had
been on more than once
no just once no you have twice you if
you did it we did an interview and we
made a really cool drink with every time
you is I the only person who knows
you've done every time you upload
it's like workout videos you never buy
me on yeah I just think that you just
don't think I can exercise okay I want
to come on for a drunken workout video
workout I want to try drunk workout that
was so fun I will get the cameraman to
be strong and it will all get drunk
yeah the actor will be trouble be drunk
when we upload a video you've ever seen